كان الرئيس بايدن يتحدث في وقت سابق
للصحفيين حول وجهة نظره عن الرئيس
بوتين بعد اجتماعه مع الأشخاص الذين
أجبرهم بوتين على مغادرة المكان الذي يعيشون فيه ،
ترى هذا
وأنت تعلم أنك تتعامل كل يوم مع
فلاديمير بوتين ،
انظر إلى ما فعله من أجل  هؤلاء الناس ،
ما الذي يجعلك تعتقد أنه
جزار ،
لذا فإن الرئيس جون الآن وصف
بوتين مجرم حرب بأنه قاتل
بلطجي خالص ، ويصفه الآن بأنه جزار لما حدث وكان الرئيس
بايدن يقول أنك تعلم أنك كنت
تراقبه يمر  والتقط الحشود
فتاة صغيرة ذات مرة ، وشبك
يديه مع امرأة أخرى وضع يديه
على كتفها كان يسمع فقط
قصصهم ويخبرهم كم كانوا شجعانًا
وكان يقول أن بعض
الأطفال الصغار الذين تعرفهم فقط  أرادوا
عناقًا وكان الكثير منهم يطلبون
منهم الدعاء من أجل آبائهم
وإخوانهم وأعمامهم الذين ما زالوا
في أوكرانيا بالطبع مع هذا التفويض
في مكانه إذا كنت بين 1  8 و
60 من سن القتال يجب أن تبقى في
أوكرانيا ، لم يُسمح لهم بمغادرة
أوكرانيا كما فعل الكثير من الآخرين
الملايين الذين فعلوا ذلك وأتوا إلى هنا